welcome to part three of native Lankans
course on using the international
phonetic alphabet to learn about
pronunciation and language this time
we'll focus on syllables the previous
two videos looked at vowels and then
consonants
if you grasp the basics of vowels and
consonants you already have the material
you need to make a syllable vowels sit
at the heart of the syllable which is
actually called the nucleus of the
syllable consonants are built around
that nucleus consonants before the vowel
before the nucleus are part of the
syllables on set there may be one or
more consonants in the onset consonants
after the vowel after the nucleus are
the coda which is Italian for tail of
the syllable so we can have syllables
with consonants before the nucleus and
then after we can have syllables with
consonants after the nucleus and none
before we can have a syllable with
consonants both before and after the
nucleus we can even have syllables with
no onset and no coda just a nucleus
languages have different ways of
building a syllable
for instance in Japanese you tend to
hear syllables that end in a vowel
syllables don't have consonants after
the nucleus these open syllables have
just a vowel or a consonant plus vowel
the vowel can be long or it can be short
but you'll still stop there so the next
consonant would be part of the following
syllable in English however we can have
open syllables just like Japanese but we
also find fairly overloaded syllables
that involve three consonants before and
three consonants after the vowel nucleus
in all cases you can still use the
concepts of syllable onset syllable
nucleus and coda to analyze syllables in
a language
we haven't yet touched on more complex
vowel nuclei like diphthongs when we
have multiple vowels within the same
nucleus that's called a diphthong many
languages have multiple vowels sitting
at the heart of the same syllable for
example the English word height contains
a diphthong I at the nucleus of the
syllable there are vowel type sounds
like the glides yo and Wu which are
represented in IPA like a J and a W yeah
and Wu are treated as consonant sounds
but their vowel like sounds that can
straddle a main valve to form a
diphthong sometimes the vowel in the
nucleus is simply held longer it's the
same vowel but it's held out for a
longer time you can represent such long
vowels in the IPA with a double mark
after the vowel so the vowel e can be
lengthened to e i've been talking about
vowel nuclei but a consonant may sit
inside the nucleus of a syllable instead
of a vowel take the English word nerve
some speakers pronounce that word nerve
with an R as a syllable nucleus when we
write syllabic consonants like this are
in art I PA it's conventional to place a
small stroke beneath the consonant to
signal that it's acting as the nucleus
let's talk a bit more generally about
transcribing speech for a moment you've
seen slashes around my IPA text these
slashes are used to open and close the
IPA characters for example this is a
transcription of the English word dashes
and this is a transcription of the
Italian word Fattah both transcriptions
are enclosed in slashes you can break
your transcription into syllables by
placing a low dot a period between each
syllable like this
these basics will get you started as you
tackle syllables in any language you're
learning join me next time for features
that apply to longer streams of sound
and check out the web page for examples
exercises and more information